the Call of Duty series has some
fantastic weapons from World Wars
overpowered mp40 to the weapon that
became a meme in modern warfare to use
intervention but the Armory's of these
games are is also always a stinker or -
a weapon that you either never used or
found so laughably bad when compared to
the rest of the munitions in the game
but you left it gathering dust in the
creator class menu from Call of Duty 4
to 20 19's modern warfare this is our
list of the worst guns in the franchise
I'll be sticking to the primaries in
this video and while I know some
received buffs and were altered over
time I'm judging them by their merits on
release and when I got to use them
regardless I'm sure you'll defend your
favorites in the comments down below the
scorpion I hated this thing this tiny
pocket pistol shot out bullets are about
as damaging as harsh language and had an
anemic magazine and ugly recall pattern
to boot if you weren't rolling stopping
power with this gun back in the day you
could sometimes expect to land up to 5
shots for a kill and considering the
magazine only holds 20 rounds that's a
pretty big ask even more so if you're
coming across more than one player it
also always felt like the muzzle flash
took up half of your sights so not only
have you got a pitiful bullet hose but
it's one with a sparkler on the end of
it your best bet was to roll with the
increased hipfire accuracy and getting
someone's face to make the most of the
rate of fire but given the strength of
this tiny little pocket pistol you're
probably gonna get dropped before you
got even close enough while there may be
a niche for this weapon when you compare
it to the other offerings in the SMG
class like the mp5 p90 or even mini Z
its firepower was found lacking the
things that the Scorpion were okay at
other SMGs were greater
[Music]
the trench gun isn't just the worst gun
in the world at war but it might be the
worst gun in the entire Call of Duty
franchise it's inconsistent have
seemingly random damage its scarce of
shots and takes so long to pump the
thing between each round the Red Army
could retake Stalingrad quicker than you
can expel the measly four rounds in your
weapon the pallets fired from the
shotguns seemed to disappear before your
very eyes reducing the damage range to
me--and meters and if you want to get a
one-shot kill with this thing then you
have to be close enough to be able to
smell the enemy's breath closing the
gaps this range is extra punishing
because if the rng gods decide that not
enough pellets have hit your target and
you have to get another shot off the
enemy has more than enough time to turn
on you and rattle you down with their
SMG or even a semi-automatic rifle I
know it's a joke in the world of arcade
FPS games the shotguns drop off after a
short range but this is easily one of
the worst offenders in the real world
Germany trying to have the use of trench
gun labelled as a war crime during the
first world war in Call of Duty however
it should be considered a punishment to
have to use one it was a challenge for
me to think of one for modern warfare 2
because even if some of the guns are
underpowered most of them are still
pretty fun to use although if I think
back I'd have to give the accolade to
the f2000 the futuristic love charm
between an assault rifle and an SMG it
was one of those guns that seems to be
trying to do too much at once
yeah the highest rate of fire of all the
assault rifle so was suited to fairly
close range engagements but at that
point you may as well use any of the
other awesome SMGs that are on offer and
considering that the f2000 wasn't even
unlocked until level 60 you no doubt
already had a favorite submachine gun
that you've sunk hours into learned
inside and out and felt much more
comfortable with over this bizarre
bullpup also this might be an aesthetic
point but it's weird it looks ugly the
EMP proof red dot sight might be a cool
gimmick but it's ugly and takes up far
too much real estate on the screen if
you wanted a fast firing assault rifle
in the modern warfare 2 you were
probably already using the ACR anyway
dez i had to think a little about mono
off had to use entry but when it came to
black ops i knew without a second
thought were the worst pepper laws do
use his problem as a mixture of low
damage high recall outrageous iron
sights and the fact other things sound
like a baby's rattle when fired back
when black ops came out and i would try
to run this weapon I found myself
screaming how are you not dead yet so
many times due to all of its downsides
it relies on attachments to make a
viable weapon or even just one you can
use without squinting and because of
that it's severely limiting and how you
can build your class especially when
there are so many other better weapons
in the same category this SMG is the
epitome of spray-and-pray
except your god just isn't listening
I've loved the Dragunov in so many games
so it was a bit disappointing for it to
feel like such a wet fart in modern
warfare 3 it's a victim of falling in
between two main schools of thought when
it comes to sniping in these games It
was as if the one hit killed ball
actions and the spammable semi
automatics were fighting for custody
over the same thing and instead it
became a rifle that would take too many
shots to kill quickly and have too much
recall to deliver follow-up damage like
many others in this list the elements
that made this weapon when it was would
just simply done better by other weapons
in its same class
Call of Duty has a weird relationship
with shotguns either they are Earth's
wonderingly good to the point of needing
a nerf or they're so pathetic you'd
probably do more damage to the enemy if
he threw the thing at them the s12 falls
into the latter category it was nice
that I had a big mag that could spew out
shots but when the spread was
inconsistent the fire rate was low and
the range had a laughably sure damage
drop-off it's no surprise this shotgun
caused much frustration and thrown
controllers ghosts is probably my least
played Call of Duty game but when I
picked up the CB JMS for the first time
I instantly felt like I was holding the
great and useless grandson of the black
ops Susy this thing could really spew
out rounds but the only hope you had in
hitting anyone with that tone of bullets
was if you were force feeding your enemy
the barrel both its recoil and its range
were horrendous sometimes dating up to
six shots to take an opposition down the
unique selling point of this weapon was
it akane with integrated anti-armor
tungsten rounds which were great in
taking down enemy equipment and
killstreaks but at what cost
this simply wasn't worth the trade-off I
know lots of players loved this weapon
but for me the em1 sounds so much cooler
on paper than it ever was in game but
naturally it became a pretty hotly
discussed topic since it's a laser
weapon that's basically hits in with
fast but tiny amounts of damage your
target tracking had to be pretty dead-on
but considering that movement and
mobility was such a big thing in
advanced warfare that felt like a pretty
big ass this is where the fan base kind
of diverges because tracking with this
thing if you were playing on PC appeared
much more viable I have vivid memories
playing with this thing on the Xbox
shortly after release and gripping my
controller with white-knuckle
frustration I know it got altered and
buffed and had variants down the line
but by that point I'd fallen away from
advanced warfare and all that was
remained of the em1 for me was a bitter
memory of the laser weapon I was so
hopeful for
I'm not sure what the thought of was
taking a sniper rifle relied on accuracy
and giving a three round burst but the
result of that board meeting was the po6
looking purely at the stats it was a
long-range sniper that fired three shots
each doing 90 damage capable of the kill
if one of those shots hit the head or
two if they hit the body
now with that description it sounds
pretty great but the feature that really
drank this thing down was that the
weapon didn't fire when you pulled the
trigger but instead charged before the
round spewed forth now take this delay
that needs compensates so much for your
shots and the time between rounds and
combined there with the over-the-top
wall running and jumping they're made of
the movement in black ops 3 and your
chances to hit your target went from
slim it's a bugger roll infinite warfare
continued the futuristic thoughts and
advanced movement war running jumping
and basically being a nightmare to hit
so it was important while playing this
game to make every shot count this is
one of the many reasons the type 2
suffered so much yeah the lowest abased
damage of any primary weapon in the game
meaning that you'd have to hit that
agile opponent jumping out of your sight
line five times in order to drop them
sure you could tear it apart into two
SMGs akimbo style but that was a gimmick
that couldn't save a lackluster assault
rifle continuing the theme of shotguns
that did a pitiful amout of damage
Call of Duty World War 2 sawed-off
shotgun again left players underwhelmed
when the game came out again this thing
received buffs but when I went back to
the game to do some capture it was still
a double-barreled wet noodle it was
about as consistent as the world at war
trench gun but with half the amount of
ammunition and a longer reload time
putting those factors up against the
other shotguns in the game left it
wanting even the Luftwaffe trilling had
the rifle round to play with if you need
a defensive utility but personally I
felt that the double barrel was a
singularly poor effort the black ops 4
Spitfire was an SMG that really didn't
live up to its namesake I know that in
blackout it felt like a different beast
and throwing on a slew of attachments
can make this thing even more viable but
when I was jumping into the world of
black ops for this thing felt more like
an out-of-control fire hose in anything
spewing flames it might have had a tasty
rate of fire but that came with a recall
profile that made it a nightmare to keep
any bunny-hopping bad guys in your
process the only time I felt confident
with this thing in a game was when I
could be sure I could get it right in
someone's face but for me it was far too
situational to be
system pick as it's based on a British
weapon I really wanted to love the sa80
7 it feels like a hybrid of a light
machine gun and the sole rifle but with
the unfortunate disadvantages of both
and few of the bonuses he was stuck with
a movement speed of an LMG a low rate of
fire a crawling aim-down-sight speed and
a grueling ly long reload for what is an
extremely small magazine for a weapon of
its class and those problems still exist
even after you've given it some care and
attention at the gunsmithing table since
mana warfare is the current Call of Duty
we're all following right now I wouldn't
be surprised if we saw this buffed in
the future but for now whenever I use
this weapon I always get that finger
that I could be doing so much better if
I just had a different gun and while the
breadth of customization options can
soften some of the rougher edges of this
thing it doesn't matter what you add on
to it you're still basically polishing a
turd well that's been my nostalgia trip
down the road of rubbish guns throughout
the franchise if you want to know more
about one of the most iconic weapons in
Call of Duty history you can check out
our loadout episode on the intervention
I'm still going to be playing through
the rest of the franchise so let us know
if you enjoy this video and maybe next
time I'll go through a list of my
favorites until then like the video if
you enjoyed and be sure to subscribe for
everything Call of Duty both old and new